it was just an ordinary Saturday
my dad was outside mowing the lawn my
mom was upstairs folding laundry my
sister was in a room doing homework and
I was in the basement playing video
games and as I came upstairs to get
something to drink
I looked out the window and real I said
there was something that was supposed to
be doing and this is what I saw no this
wasn't my family's dinner on fire this
was my science project flames were
pouring out smoke was in the air and
that look like a wooden deck was about
to catch fire I immediately started
yelling my mom was freaking out my dad
ran around to put out the fire and of
course my sister started recording a
snapchat video this was just the
beginning of my team science project my
team is composed to me and through other
students who are here in the audience
today
we competed in FIRST LEGO League which
is an international Lego robotics
competition for kids in in addition to
robotics game we also worked on a
separate science project and this was
the project that we were working on so
the idea for this project all started
when a few months earlier a couple of my
teammates took a trip to Central America
and saw beaches littered with styrofoam
or expanded polystyrene foam and when
they came back and told us about it we
really started thinking about the ways
in which we see styrofoam every day get
a new flat-screen TV you end up with a
block of styrofoam bigger than the TV
itself drink a cup of coffee with those
styrofoam coffee cups are sure gonna add
up and worry all these items go after
their one-time use since there are any
good existing solutions for you
styrofoam almost all of them end up
riding the landfill or the oceans and
beaches taking over 500 years to degrade
and in fact every year the US alone
through this is over 2 billion pounds of
styrofoam filling up a staggering 25% of
landfills so why do we have these ghosts
accumulations of styrofoam waste why
can't we just recite
like many plastics well simply put
recycled polystyrene is too expensive
and potentially contaminated so there is
very little market demand for styrofoam
that has to be recycled and as a result
styrofoam is considered a non-renewable
material because it is neither feasible
nor viable to recycle polystyrene and in
fact many cities across the u.s. have
even passed ordinances that simply ban
the production of many products
containing polystyrene which includes
disposable utensils packing peanuts
takeout containers and even plastic
Beach toys all products were very useful
in today's society and now France has
become the first country to completely
ban all plastic utensils cups and plates
but what if we could keep using
styrofoam and keep benefiting from its
cheap lightweight insulating an
excellent patent ability while not
having to suffer from the repercussions
of having to dispose of it what if we
could turn it into something else that's
actually useful what if we can make the
impossible possible my team Apophis
sized that we could use the carbon that
is already in styrofoam to create
activated carbon which is used in almost
every water filter today an activated
carbon works by using very small micro
pores to filter out contaminants from
water or even air so we started out by
doing a variety of heating tests and
unfortunately we had many failures
literally nothing worked
besides my dad's cool kitchen on fire
most of our samples vaporized into
nothing or exploded inside expensive
furnaces leaving a horribly sticky mess
in fact we were so saddened by our
failures that we almost gave up so why
did we keep trying when all the adults
said it was impossible
well maybe it's because for kids we
don't know any better but the truth is
we kept trying B's we thought it was
still possible we knew that if we were
successful we will be hoping the
environment and making the world a
better place so we kept trying and
failing and trying and failing we were
so ready to give up but then it happened
with the right temperatures times and
chemicals we find
we got that successful test result
showing us that we had created activity
carbon from styrofoam waste and at that
moment the thing that had been
impossible
all of a sudden wasn't it showed us -
although we had many failures at the
beginning we were able to persevere
through them to get the test results
that we wanted and moreover not only
were we able to create activated carbon
for purifying water but we were also
able to reduce styrofoam waste solving
to global problems with just one
solution so from then on we were
inspired to take our project further
performing more tests to make it more
effective and testing it in real-world
situations we then proceeded to receive
funding from the nstac East cyber
mission stem and action program
sponsored by the US Army as well as
first global Innovation Awards sponsored
by XPrize and we were also honored with
society with the Scientific American
innovator award from Google science fair
and using these funds we plan to file a
full patent on our process and to
continue to work on our project so yes
all that we started with filling with
catching my dad's girl on fire and
filling so many times that we almost
quit it was well worth it when we look
back in it now we took a problem that
many people said was impossible and we
made it possible and we persevered when
it looked like nothing that we did would
work we learned you can't have success
without a little or a lot of failure so
in the future don't be afraid if your
girl goes up in flames because you never
know when your idea might just catch
fire thank you
[Applause]